go to the red hot center of
what's important in somebody's life
because that's where you get the truth
in this era most people are skeptical
distrustful of the news media
everyone is a journalist you gather
information
verify it and communicate it
everyone has their own version of the
truth but
there are facts
i'm going to teach in this class is the
importance of
human sources no one ever gives you the
full story
often it's a mix of truth and untruth
the job is to go verify i shall resign
the presidency effective at noon
tomorrow
the president of the united states is
not above the law
the human source is the savior of
journalism
in this semester class i'm going to
teach you research
investigating how to gather information
how to interview people and how to
find the story and build the story
the purpose of an interview is not
gotcha it's not to catch
i have a little technique of sticking
this finger
over my little finger jamming it down so
it hurts
and it's a reminder to shut up
and just listen let the silence suck out
the truth
this is the time we're being tested
let's tell the truth
let's not be chicken about this break
the rules
not the law but the rules this is
the final exam for democracy
i'm bob woodward and this is my master
class
you